hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wie heute zu einem neuen video ich habe
mir gedacht ich zocke wieder date arien
und zwar geht es halt darum dass wir
eine person bacon und wir müssen anhand
der sachen die wir auswählen versuchen
so lange wie möglich bei ihr zu bleiben
das at that thought there is a fellow
americans to meet you come on let's get
no isabella und jetzt können wir uns
hier eine von den vier sachen auswählen
ich hab das ja schon zweimal hochgeladen
heute wird das allerdings nicht so und
zwar habe ich mir nämlich fotos gemacht
von ottfried also hier so sieht das
gerade auf meinem handy aus habe ich mir
ein paar sachen hier abfotografiert wo
ein paar witzige sachen passieren
deswegen gehen wir dieses thema durch
laute müssen wir erstmal etwas witziges
sagen dann müssen wir sie küssen dann
sagen wir ohne tiebreak mit tänzen jetzt
gehe ich mit fingern durch ihre haare
jetzt mache ich ein bisschen wie kann
dann werde ich mal die rock play taste
hört übrigens gerade keinen ton weil ich
meine eigenen hintergrund gepackt hat
weil ich mir wirklich nicht so ganz
sicher bin ob ich recht an der musik da
habe ich jetzt mal die musik und machen
leid jazz und dabei die end to end
okay da sind keine titten alles klar
awesome uhr let's go pubic jetzt und
dann sollen wir pizza bestellt
jetzt irgendwie wie lang lagern die
duden 2000 jahre später jetzt irgendwas
mit wein jetzt die pizza jetzt gering
ein denn blablabla sie just fine way to
clean and quickly sie geht jetzt ins
badezimmer ich warte im whole way und
jetzt nutze ich das bad und jetzt ist
das werk nummer 1 auf der website stand
nämlich um die sachen zu erreichen muss
man erst mal diese grundlage schaffen
was wir jetzt gerade hier geschafft
haben deswegen speicher ich das ganze
jetzt erstmal jetzt kommen nämlich
zuerst sache und zwar ist das sex
amerikanisch das heißt wenn ihr jetzt
unter 18 seid bitte abschalten freunde
muss das halt immer sagen ich weiß ganz
genau dass keiner von euch abschalten
wie hielt wir gehen tanzen in dem
wohnzimmer jetzt machen wir romantik
playlist change
jetzt gehen wir mal wo anders sehen und
zwar in das wohnzimmer jetzt müssen wir
sie damit irgendwie die couch irgendwie
öffnen oder so so jetzt gress genau
jetzt können wir die brüste anfassen
jetzt sollen wir sie fragen ob sie ihr
shirt auszieht und das soll sie jetzt
angeblich auch machen also ich mach das
mal und sie zieht es sich aus ich hab da
wahrscheinlich gerade irgendeinen filter
darübergelegt hier bei myvideo deswegen
damit ihr das genick seht und youtube
das video nicht sperrt und
jetzt steht ihr kind hört ist das jetzt
schon große titten jetzt rapport fix ich
weiß nicht was das ist okay das im
oberschenkel die ich jetzt gerade von
ihr ab jetzt gehörte take that fans auf
ein paar sekunden später
wir sind tatsächlich schon an ihrem po
angelangt jetzt massieren wir ihren
rücken der pole stich tatsächlich schon
sehr krass gerade raus adrian sagt
gerade do me now und sie liegt dort um
komplett nackt youtube bitte macht es
nicht ab 18
was das was was tue ich hier mit meinem
leben ein paar sekunden später und
schade das war jetzt allerdings erst die
erste sache die ich rausgesucht habe
jetzt machen wir mal das zweite was ich
noch im internet gefunden habe wir sind
wir wieder bei unserem checkpoint
angelangt und jetzt sollen wir nämlich
direkt in den living nun gehen dann ihre
schultern massieren dann irgendwo anders
hingehen und jetzt in beck ja was ist
denn acht genau da am pool wieder herbe
drink checker die telescope jetzt soll
ich glaube ich wieder die frage
beantworten und zwar drei teams anleihen
die bei der eaa decker ich hab's richtig
beantwortet ja man das ist so geil
diesmal sagt sie einfach alle just take
off my shirt und dabei sieht sie so aus
also die die nippel sind schon zu sehen
aber ich hab da wahrscheinlich wieder
gerade was drüber gelegt alles klar
sie springt einfach obenrum nackt aber
unten rum mit einer hose und schule in
den pool was ist wenn ich jetzt noch mal
drauf steht ist das waren lauter sound
erinnern sagt einfach einbauen liedes we
miss you to rock'n'roll und steht hier
mit mit ihrem po oder halb und den den
das ist doch die freunde man dass das
dass das spiel ist ist das spiel
überhaupt ab 18 oder 21 sie tanzen liegt
was soll ich denn machen weil ich ab
minderjährige zuschauer und wir sind
wieder an im moment angekommen wo ich an
ihren nippeln lutscher dass das ist
super cool ich weiß wirklich nicht
freunde ob ihr das hier gerade feiert
oder ob es einmal nur verstören ist es
auf jeden fall leiter sich hochgeladen
habe okay freunde ich will euch das gar
nicht zeigen was ich gerade sehr okay
doch hier
ich hab mal einfach smileys darüber
gesetzt was was ihren was ihr da das ich
massiere gerade ihre ja genau
ich bin raus ich will diese spiele heft
in great software.com titel doing that
on thursday ich habe halt nach oralsex
gefragt aber ich glaube die man mag das
nicht so ok schmeiß mich einfach raus
und ich bin wieder am startbildschirm
das ist auf jeden fall ein tolles ende
das war es hier auch schon vom video
meine damen und herren ich hoffe deshalb
hatte ich bin total verwirrt im kopf
weil ihm die idee ist dass das war ein
krankes video man ich könnte wirklich
1000 euro verwetten dass dieses video ab
+ 18 freigegeben wird von youtube
deswegen herzlichen glück und wenn ihr
es euch relativ schnell angesehen habe
dann alle eure freunde ich noch unter 18
sendern vielleicht das noch sehen wollen
dann schickt ihn lieber schnell weil ich
glaube in mindestens zwei minuten ist es
ab 18 verfügbar sonst sehen wir uns
vielleicht irgendwann in der neuen part
von batterien ich denke zwar dass ich
nicht immer hochladen werden ayachi